the popcorn for up to 5 minutes talk
about whatever you want really
just what just whatever I want like just
it could be just random like me just
talking right now this is life whatever
I want both to five minutes so something
that's been on my mind lately is that
I've like kind of started reconnecting
with my parents and I've noticed that
they're becoming like younger and
younger and spirit and I used to think
that like I would grow up to be like
them but I feel like they're growing up
to be like us in a way and it's kind of
cool to see like people of older
generations kind of like adjusting to
the changes and like how fast the world
is
it's really interesting to see what we
can learn from them and what we can
teach them too my message is families
always gonna be dead no matter what
Natalie
family will just as to me is just what I
learned is past years I've gone through
some situations you know by myself and
other people
I don't know who to go to and I was I
should just left my family at that point
but came back to them and they they
still respected me and they still
accepted me
[Music]
I'm I'm reading this book
it's Italians name is Don the camera
dropper and the translation it's
girl who loves to Martha and it's very
interesting book and it is the what I
use for well I don't know what can I say
and it's all my friends in Italy we make
me a party before I live left or going
here and happy that that's enough I just
wanna say that I like this country a lot
I was talking this morning to my part
about how Mexico is so corrupted how am
I really enjoying living here I'm
working here for now and that means that
I'm a taxpayer here I have never been so
happy
paying taxes
because here like you get what you
should get that is like safety education
good freeways clean streets many Mexico
less doesn't happens so it's not that I
love governmental systems but we have to
happen or at least we're having them for
now
I feel that
this is a very good system that it works
so congratulations to all the Americans
for having this government I think
that you should already leave proud of
it and you need to make America great
again it's already a great country and I
think that same
[Music]
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]